10 teenager feierten eine party und
plötzlich bericht ein 16-jähriges
mädchen zusammen
die sanitäter und der notarzt die haben
noch versucht das mädchen zu retten aber
sie ist verstorben die partygäste als
die party gäste erzählten hinterher der
polizei dass die 16 jährige alkohol
getrunken und drogen genommen haben soll
kai feldhaus ist jetzt bei mir im studio
kai du kennst den fall ein bisschen
genauer wir wissen bild hat mit der
mutter gesprochen von celina wie geht es
ihr die mutter von siena hat bis heute
nicht realisiert dass ihre tochter
verstorben ist dass sie nicht mehr nach
hause kommt das hat sich den kollegen
thomas knoop noel altendorf erzählt die
sie interviewt haben
berlin hat er gerade die schule fertig
sie hat eine ausbildung ein
ausbildungsplatz machte träume wie die
mädchen mit 16 jahren nun mal haben und
die mutter sagte die rechnet immer noch
damit dass die tür aufgeht und das kind
da reinkommt dieser albtraum dann vorbei
ist und sie bedeutet auch immer wieder
ihre tochter habe mit drogen nichts am
hut gehabt
das beteuert zwar wissen wir was in den
letzten stunden passiert ist heißt ja
sie soll alkohol getrunken haben und
drogen genommen haben tatsächlich ist
die linie aufgebrochen zu einer
geburtstagsparty einer freundin hat sich
noch fröhlich von ihrer mutter
verabschiedet und was da noch dieser
partie passierte das hat sich die mutter
jetzt über die aussagen von freunden und
freundinnen die dort fanden
zusammengereimt offenbar ist sie ihn
danach zum 1 bewusstlos
zusammengebrochen
das hat dann auch mal noch eine weile
gedauert bis der notruf verständigt
wurde warum das so ist das ist noch
unklar
und als der notarzt an dabei hat er noch
versucht das mädchen wiederzubeleben das
ist aber nicht gelungen
was genau jetzt ursächlich war das da
stehen die ermittlungen der polizei die
die jetzt sich dieser sache angenommen
hat noch ganz am anfang da muss jetzt
erstmal die todesursache geklärt werden
da muss dann ein toxikologisches
gutachten angefertigt werden um
festzustellen ob tatsächlich existiere
sächlich war für den tod von celina und
wenn das der fall ist dann werden die
partygäste dazu
die entzündung das heißt das ganze steht
eigentlich noch komplett am anfang der
aufklärung ja das kriegt das ist steht
noch ganz am anfang
freunde haben der mutter erzählt dass
dass es wegen der dreiecks sie tabletten
von anderen anwesenden jugendlichen
bekommen hat und diese auch wieder
aufgenommen hat und sollte dem so sein
dann stehen da natürlich auch
entsprechend strafen ins haus dann kann
das ganze mit einer freiheitsstrafe
sogar enden für denjenigen der sie mit
den tabletten versorgt hat wir sind bild
und wie ihr liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren